Donald Trump is promising mandatory
homeless camps ban urban camping
wherever possible violators of these
bands will be arrested but they will be
given the option to accept treatment and
services if they're willing to be
rehabilitated many of them don't want
that there's a lot of historical
precedent for these sorts of camps being
some of the ugliest things that
societies do I mean not only is it
inhumane and violates basic human rights
it also doesn't work homelessness has so
many complex factors that causes it
poverty is of course part of it mental
illness is a component addiction is a
component lack of affordable housing in
cities is a component lack of effective
public transportation there's so many
different factors but what it should the
takeaway should be is
if you just criminalize homelessness it
doesn't really solve anything